The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So Phil is going to
do the next three recitations.
So the first one
today is really going
to focus on how do you actually
debug programs on cell.
How many people in
here have used gdb,
or are familiar with gdb?
OK, good.
So there's going to be
a mini tutorial on how
to run programs and
attach gdb, which
is a debugger that's commonly
used for debugging programs.
We'll show you how to
debug PPU and SPU programs.
And he's going to talk a little
bit about some other things
that might help you in terms
of performance debugging,
finding out where things are
not going as well or as fast
as you might expect them to.
And the next two recitations,
which will be next week,
will focus on doing some
actual performance-specific
optimizations.
So you've written your program.
It's working.
Well, the
functionality is there.
But it's not performing
as fast as you might like.
Or you think you can improve
performance a bit better.
So what can you do?
So he'll show you some tricks
and some things you can
do to get the performance up.
For some of you who have
asked about the Eclipse
debugger, the Eclipse IDE,
it does run reasonably
slowly on the PlayStation 3
because of memory constraints.
So if you have lots of people
trying to use it on the PS3,
it'll probably be unusable.
So for those of you
who are interested,
we'll just do separate
tutorials offline.
Because I don't
know how many people
will actually end up using it.
Other than that, [INAUDIBLE].
PHIL: All right.
So today we'll talk about
how to run gdb on Cell.
And then we'll also do
some static profiling
where you can figure
out when instructions
are going to be executed.
And then I'll talk a little
bit about the dynamic profiling
tools that we have available.
So you can use gdb to examine
the state of your program.
And this can help you figure
out bugs that you might have.
There's two ways
that you can use gdb.
The first way is when
your program crashes,
you can figure out what
was happening at the time
that it crashed.
Another way that you can
use gdb is to kind of run it
from the beginning.
You attach gdb to your
program, and then you
step through all the things,
all the instructions that
are being executed
while the program runs.
In order for gdb to be able
to provide useful information
about the state of
your program, you
have to give it a little help.
You need to compile your
program using gcc -g.
xlc -g will also work.
This puts in some extra
information into your program
so that when gdb is looking
at the state of your program,
it's able to figure out what
line numbers in the source code
that corresponds to.
So you can just
add dash g manually
to your GCC invocations, or you
can also set this compiler--
or you can set this option
in the makefile, CC_OPT_LEVEL
and set that to
CC_OPT_LEVEL_DEBUG.
And that will do the same
thing as adding dash g.
All right?
Now we have a special
version of gdb
available for use on the Cell.
ppu-gdb is used for
debugging ppu and spu
programs after they've
been linked together.
And how you invoke
it if you're going
to run your entire program
using gdb is you type ppu-gdb
and then the name
of your program.
And what you get is
a gdb prompt where
you can issue additional
commands to the debugger
to control execution
of your program,
and also ask the
debugger to tell you
various things
about your program.
One thing you can do is export
SPU_INFO=1 before you start
your program.
And that will print some
extra debugging information
about when threads are
being created and destroyed.
Like I mentioned,
you can also use gdb
to attach to a program
that's already running.
And if you want to do
that you still need
to provide the executable name.
And you also provide the process
ID of the program to attach to.
PROFESSOR: Do people know
how to get the process ID?
[INAUDIBLE] How many
people don't know?
The easiest way to do
it is if your program's
running just type "top."
And that'll actually show you
what's running on your machine.
And there'll be a column
that has a process ID.
Another thing you can
do is just type "ps."
We'll add those to the
recitation slides. [INAUDIBLE].
PHIL: So I forgot to mention.
If you're invoking
your program with gdb,
then after you type ppu-gdb
with your executable name,
gdb is just going to sit there
and wait for instructions.
And what you can do
is type "run" and that
will run your program normally.
But the difference is
that gdb will pick up
and if something goes wrong.
And then that's where you can
step in and look at the program
state.
So what kind of things can you
figure out about your program?
Anytime you have this gdb prompt
and your program is running,
you can type "bt" to get a
stack trace for your program.
And this will tell
you which functions
are calling which functions.
It's going to give
you a list of frames.
And the top one is
going to correspond
to the deepest level
of function nesting,
or the deepest function
call in the program.
And of course, the
last one on the list
is going to be the main or the
first function that was called.
That make sense?
And for each stack
frame gdb will tell you
the name of the function.
And if source code
is available it
will tell you also which
file the function is
running in right now,
and at which line number.
And so using that
information you
can figure out exactly where it
was that this function called
the next function and where
was that each function called
the next function after that.
Now whenever you've
halted the program state,
you can get information about
what the local variables are.
And to do that you
can type "info locals"
and it will print a list
of all the local variables
and their values.
gdb, because it gets annotations
from the compiled program,
it knows about what data
types are associated
with which variables.
And so it will be able to
format the output appropriately.
So for example, it knows
that i is an integer.
Whereas if you had i as, for
example, a floating point
number, it would print
that floating point number
representation instead.
Instead of looking
at single variables
you can also ask gdb to evaluate
arbitrary expressions for you.
And this is actually a
really powerful facility.
You can pretty much type any
expression that you would be
able to use in C or C++.
When you type
"print VARNAME" gdb
will look up that
variable name for you.
But sometimes if you have
more than one variable
available in your function
under the same name,
for example, these variables
are in different files
or different functions
that are all available,
then you may need to
disambiguate the variable name.
And to do that you just
proceed the variable name
with either the file name that
you want to use or the function
that the variable occurs in.
Any questions?
OK.
And because gdb knows which
line numbers the programs
is executing right
now, then it's
able to show you the
source code corresponding
to the current place
in the program.
And in order to browse the
source code, if it's available
you just type "list."
In general whenever gdb has
stopped in a certain place
you can type "list" to get
a listing of the source
code near that location.
And what list will
do, by default,
is show 10 lines of source code
near where the program stopped.
If you type "list" again it will
show 10 lines following that.
And you can keep typing "list"
to browse the source code.
You can also get the code that's
at a particular line number
if you want to look at
another place in your program.
All right, so this is how to
use gdb to actually control
the flow of your program.
If you invoke gdb to
start up your program,
then you can type "run" and
that will run your program
with a normal flow of execution.
And it will only stop
when errors occur.
But you can use a
couple of these commands
to actually go step by
step through your program.
And wait for one line
to be executed, and then
decide whether you want to
look at the next line or not.
If you want to do this kind
of step-by-step execution
you start by using the
start command instead
of the run command, which
will run continuously.
Then anytime you want to
jump to the next instruction,
you can use next to
get to the next line
in the current procedure.
You can also use
step, which, if there
are function calls
on the current line,
will descend into
those function calls
and show you what's
going on over there.
And if you're inside
a function call
you can type "finish"
in order to jump
back to right after
the function call ends
in the caller of that function.
And if you want to stop
line-by-line execution
you can type "continue"
and it will just
continue without interruptions.
Any questions?
Basically any time you use one
of these line-by-line commands
gdb will show you the
line that you're on.
And if your program just
jumped into a new function
or something, then it will
also show you what function
and what file you're in.
So this is very helpful
for following what's
going on in your program.
OK.
So in addition to just
running through your program
step by step, you
can also choose
to only stop your program
when certain things happen.
So this is very
useful for debugging
certain pieces of code where
the code is very deeply
nested inside and you don't want
to step all the way to there.
You just want to stop
when you get there.
And gdb allows you to
define breakpoints, which
are places in your source code.
And once gdb gets to a point
of execution which corresponds
to that point in
your source code,
it will stop and
ask you what to do.
You can set a breakpoint
that's associated
with any particular
function in your source code
or any particular--
well, what you can do
is if you do break
function then it
will create a new breakpoint.
And it will stop
execution any time
you get to the beginning
of that function.
But you can also
set break points
in the interior of a function
by using line numbers.
All right?
Any questions?
Now sometimes you want a little
bit more flexibility than that
in setting breakpoints.
If you only want
to set a breakpoint
to happen when a certain
condition is true-- this
is helpful if you're trying
to track down a bug-- then
you can write "break"
and any of these things,
and then "if expression."
And again, you can use
any sort of expression
that you'd be able to use in C.
And what gdb will do
is every time execution
runs up to that line it will
evaluate the expression.
And only if that
expression is true will
it stop to ask you for control.
At any time you can
see which breakpoints
are active by doing info
breakpoints at the gdb prompt.
And you can also remove
breakpoints at any time.
When each breakpoint is
created it's given this number.
And the numbers start from one.
And to remove a breakpoint
you just do remove
followed by the number
that was assigned.
In addition to breaking, you
can also set a watchpoint.
What this does is it will
halt your program every time
a particular value changes.
And this is useful for tracking
down certain kinds of bugs.
If you're trying
to figure out where
a certain value for
a variable came from,
there could potentially be many,
many places in your program
where that value is set.
And you don't want to have to
set a breakpoint for all those
and watch them.
So you can instead
set a watchpoint
which will just tell you
when that value is set.
Watchpoints work a
lot like breakpoints.
If you do info breakpoints it
will also list the watchpoints.
And I believe you
can also remove
them the same way with remove.
All right, so I mentioned how
you can examine your program
state by looking at the
values of local variables.
If you want a more
low level view
of what's going on
in your program,
you can actually look
at the raw memory.
And gdb allows you to
specify an address.
And it will tell you
exactly what data is stored
in the memory at that address.
But because there's not
necessarily annotation info
telling gdb what kind of data
is stored at that address,
and of course,
there's multiple ways
you can interpret any
particular piece of data,
you'll have to tell gdb
exactly how you want
that data to be interpreted.
So you can interpret any
particular block of memory
as, for example, a series
of machine instructions.
Then gdb will tell you what the
instructions are as if you were
looking at an assembly listing.
You can ask gdb to
interpret the memory as
if it were an array of
integers and print them out
either in hex or in decimal.
You can ask gdb to display the
data as if they were addresses
or floating point numbers.
And how you do this is you type
x for examine memory and slash.
And then the number
following is the number
of words you want to look at.
And then the letter corresponds
to one of these letters
and tells gdb how to
format the output.
And then the address will be
the starting block of where you
want to start examining memory.
All right?
Any questions about this?
OK, so I mentioned that at any
time when you stop your program
there are going to be
multiple function calls which
are active, corresponding
to main, which called
this other function, which
called this other function,
which called wherever your
current point of execution is.
And you can actually
examine the state
for all of these stack
frames separately.
When you do bt it's going to
give you the list of frames.
And they're going to
be numbered from 0
to however many there are.
And you can jump to any
of them by using frame
and the appropriate number.
And it's going to
default to frame zero,
which is the closest to where
your program is actually
executing.
But you can examine the state in
frames which are further away.
So that means when you're
evaluating variables,
each variable only makes
sense in the context
of a particular frame.
And you're able to
go up the call stack
to figure out what the value
of a particular variable
is in this function, which
called this other function.
You can also use the
commands up and down
to just jump to the
immediately adjacent frames.
All right?
OK, so you can use gdb
from emacs as well.
And emacs provides a really
handy interface for gdb.
If you do M-x gdb emacs
will invoke gdb for you.
And when you do
this, you're going
to want to tell emacs to use
ppu gdb instead of regular gdb.
And emacs will just ask you
what you want to invoke.
You just want to replace
gdb with ppu gdb.
Anytime you're
debugging within emacs,
if emacs has your
source code files open,
it will show you the
current point of execution
by drawing a little arrow
next to the particular line
in the buffer.
You also get a bunch
of keyboard shortcuts
that you can use to do
some common operations.
You can set breakpoints
with Control X Space,
just by placing your cursor
at the particular line
that you want to stop at.
So you don't have to go
to gdb and type break
whatever whatever.
But when you do
m-x gdb in emacs,
you get a separate
buffer for gdb.
And so you can issue all the
commands that you normally
would want to.
OK, so the first
thing we're going
to try-- this should
be really quick--
is we're just going to
open up a brief program
and make sure you
can invoke gdb on it.
And you'll have to
set Cell top if you
don't have that set already.
I'm just going to do
it on the same one.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: How do
you exit gdb again?
PHIL: Oh, you can do
Quit or Control D.
So once you've attached gdb to
a program, when you exit gdb
it will quit the program
that you were running,
unless you do detach first.
For this one it
doesn't really matter,
because we're looking
at a crash anyway.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
Anybody [INAUDIBLE]?
OK.
AUDIENCE: How do you evaluate
something [INAUDIBLE]?
PHIL: You can evaluate an
expression using Print.
OK, any questions?
All right, so all
I did here was run
and then the program crashes.
This is just lab one without the
alignment in the control block
that you need to make
everything work correctly.
And so all I did
here was run and then
the program crashes
and then print cb.
And of course,
this thing is going
to be 0 because the DMA transfer
to do that doesn't work.
Questions?
OK so we can exit the
debugger with Control D.
And it'll ask if you
want to kill the program.
So gdb also has
features to help you
with debugging programs
that have multiple threads.
Whenever a new thread is created
or a thread is destroyed,
gdb will print a brief
message to tell you.
And one important thing is
it will print this LWP number
on the PlayStations.
To get a list of threads
you can type info threads.
And gdb always
maintains this thing
called the current thread.
And by default, when you do
many of these other actions
they're going to apply
to the current thread.
And so to examine things
about other threads
you're going to have
to change the thread.
And to do that you do
thread and some number.
When you do info
threads, it's going
to give you this
list of threads which
are numbered, for example,
1, 2, 3 on the left.
And the LWP numbers
that are displayed
are going to correspond
to these that came up
when the threads were started.
But you're going to have to
use these numbers on the left
to switch between threads.
And when you do
info threads, gdb
will mark the current thread
with a star on the left.
And it will also show
you where each thread
is executing right now.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Where does it
show you [INAUDIBLE]?
PHIL: It will show the procedure
and the file name and line
number, if that
information is available.
PROFESSOR: If you can't
find out which [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: That's
what I was saying--
PHIL: Ah.
No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I don't believe
you can get that information.
We can check.
David, do you know?
Sorry [INAUDIBLE].
So David says
maybe you can do it
on a simulator, but
not [INAUDIBLE].
PHIL: OK.
So we're going to try
this brief exercise, which
is just to get you to work with
dealing with multiple threads.
And what you're going
to do is load the lab 1
program, which is the correctly
working solution for lab 1.
And if you'll recall, this
program has multiple threads.
The PPU thread maintains
an array of control blocks.
And it's going to send the
addresses of those control
blocks to the SPUs.
So what we're going
to do is we're just
going to set breakpoints
at the right places
to verify that the first SPU
thread is getting the control
block which is the same
as one of the control
blocks in the PPU program.
All right, any
questions about that?
This is in [? rec ?] 4, lab 1.
So you're going to have
to run and set breakpoints
at the right places.
And you're going to want to set
one break point in each thread
to be able to examine the value
of CB that's being produced.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
right after the recitation.
As another exercise for those
of you who did get through,
the way you'll actually
run into these problems
is you'll run your
program and you
might end up with a bus error.
So what you might want
to do is then launch gdb.
And you run to the error.
And then you trace back
in the execution to see,
uh-oh, is my control
block value matching?
So you might want to try that
for the second exercise online.
PHIL: Should do the
stack profiling thing?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, just go
through that. [INAUDIBLE].
PHIL: OK.
So one problem that
you may have run into
is that gdb will remove
breakpoints from threads
that exit, which is a problem
if you have more than one thread
running the same program.
And if you're
debugging SPU programs,
gdb may complain about not being
able to find the source files.
But if you just
ignore that message,
it seems to find
them OK, I think.
You can use SPU gdb to debug
the SPU programs by themselves.
You can try that sometime.
OK, so actually figuring
out what the errors are,
unfortunately you don't
get very much information
from the actual
errors that occur.
But maybe looking at where
the errors are occurring
can help you figure things out.
If you've run into
memory misalignment
problems or the problem in
the last recitation where
we had DMA transfers
that were too big,
those are all going
to be bus errors.
Under various
other circumstances
you might get
segmentation faults.
And if you think your program
is running into a deadlock,
you can also use gdb to kind
of attach to the program
and then examine the
state of that program
to see what's waiting for what.
OK, so static profiling.
We have some tools
for the Cell that
will allow you to, when you
have a sequence of assembly
instructions, figure out when
those instructions are going
to get scheduled and how fast
the resulting sequence will
run.
So in order to take
advantage of this
you need to use GCC dash big
S to generate your assembly.
And you can also
do that with xlc.
If you're using
our makefiles you
can also use make whatever
file named dot s in order
to generate the assembly
from your source code.
Then once you have
the dot s file
you can run this utility
called SPU timing.
And what SPU timing
does is it will
take all the instructions
that are in your assembly
and figure out the
dependencies between them.
And then it will figure
out when the earliest
point is that each
instruction can get executed.
And it will print out the
schedule that's generated.
So if you provide the
dash running count option,
then it will also
show you how many
cycles in all the entire
program will take.
And the output goes into
file name dot s dot timing.
So for how instructions are
scheduled on Cell, if you'll
recall, there's two
pipelines for different kinds
of instructions.
And some instructions
can only run on one
or the other of the pipelines.
And some instructions
can run on both.
Now, how Cell actually
schedules those instructions is
it's always going to go in
order that the instructions are
specified in the binary.
And whenever there's two
instructions next to each other
and the first instruction
can run on pipeline zero
and the second instruction
can run on pipeline one,
then Cell will try and schedule
those at the same time.
And that's called dual issue.
So if you were taking
advantage of that dual issue
all the time, then
potentially you
could schedule two
instructions every cycle.
Oh yes, and unlike a lot of
other architectures nowadays,
Cell does not have dynamic
rent branch prediction.
All the branch prediction is
encoded inside the assembly
that you're using.
So that means for any
type of loop or whatever,
you have to be sure to get
the branch prediction right.
If the branch
prediction is wrong,
Cell is going to end up
pre-fetching instructions
along the wrong line.
And it's going to have to
stall by about 20 cycles
when it figures out that
the branch is wrong.
So if you're looking at the
generated assembly on Cell,
all the instructions are going
to be of the form operation,
then the destination register,
and then two or more sources.
And if you're trying to
just kind of orient yourself
in the generated assembly,
there are sometimes
these helpful markers.
So if you're looking at
the generated assembly
for dist_spu, then
it's going to have
a header at the top
which says which files
were included inside this file.
And then where the
actual assembly
is there'll be these markers
that say, for example, location
1 19.
And what this means is that here
is the assembly corresponding
to file 1 line 19.
So that's kind of
helpful if you're
trying to get your bearings
inside the assembly.
Because otherwise it's really
hard to make heads or tails of.
Questions?
All right, so after you
actually run your assembly
through the static profiler,
it will spit out this schedule.
And what the schedule shows
is which clock cycles are used
for every single instruction.
There's one line for each
assembly instruction.
And what it's
going to do is it's
going to print one digit in
this schedule for each cycle
that the instruction takes.
All right?
So you can kind of
think of this dimension
as the passage of time.
And what happens
is that these guys,
when they get to
the right-hand side,
they'll wrap around it
50 columns or whatever.
And you'll be able to notice
when these instructions are
being scheduled.
And sometimes when
there's dependencies
between instructions,
the instructions
are not able to get scheduled
at the earliest possible time.
And when that happens
you'll see these dashes,
which mean that the instruction
is being stalled to wait
for one of the dependencies.
In order to make
your code fast you're
going to want to
eliminate these stalls.
And you can do that
to a large extent
by reordering your instructions.
AUDIENCE: Can you stop
at the previous slide?
PHIL: Yep.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: The point of
instruction scheduling
[INAUDIBLE].
PHIL: So the point of
instruction scheduling
is going to be to minimize
the number of stalls.
And you can do that by, if
you have instructions which
are going to be dependencies
for other instructions,
you just want to move
those as far up as you can.
PROFESSOR: So ideally you would
get to instructions per cycle,
or how many instructions
can you use per cycle?
Two, because you can have
dual issue, two pipelines.
Or how many cycles per
instruction [INAUDIBLE]
by a half.
Because you're getting two
instructions per cycle,
so [INAUDIBLE].
So we have an
exercise that actually
has you understand
the assembly code,
and then doing the
instruction reordering.
So we'll leave
that on the slides.
You can do it offline.
But we'll pick up
with this next week
and go over instruction
scheduling, some DMA tricks
for improving performance.
And in particular, the thing
we'll focus on quite rigorously
is [INAUDIBLE].
So Phil's going to walk you
through how you actually
[? synchronize ?]
and get performance
from the vectorization
and the intrinsics.
We'll talk a little bit about
[? heat ?] dynamic profiling.
And for those of you who are
still having problems with gdp,
we'll try to resolve those
now since it'll probably be
very useful for your projects.
And we installed CVS in the
main directory on every PS3,
for those of you
who actually want
to use it and go through
the trouble of setting up
their own CVS.
The CVS that's
satisfied actually
notified the local
users on that machine.
So that would be
everybody on your team.
It will send out an
email whenever somebody
does a check-in or
an import, to let
them know that there's some
new information that they
don't want to update.
If you don't know how to use
CVS or want a quick tutorial,
just stop by.
Some of the TAs will
be able to help you.
OK?
[INAUDIBLE]